en italie les brigades rouges
silencieuse depuis quatre mois ont
réussi aujourd'hui à faire à nouveau la
une des journaux italiens
les terroristes ont frappé un grand coup
en enlevant hier après midi à vérone
james d'osier général américain chef
d'état major adjoint des forces
terrestres de l'otan pour l'europe du
sud
c'est la première fois que les brigades
rouges s'attaque à une personnalité
étrangère
on ne connaît pas encore les
revendications tout ce que l'on sait
d'après leur communiqué c'est que je
cite le bourreau de l'otan est enfermé
dans une prison du peuple c'est donc le
même scénario qui recommence victor
vraiment nous rappelle les tristes
prouesses des brigades rouges
c'est le 16 mars 1978 que l'italie
découvre vraiment les brigades rouges
cette fois il ne s'agit plus d'un simple
attentats les terroristes enlève en
pleine rue le président de la démocratie
chrétienne aldo moro et exécutant
quelques secondes
ces cinq gardes du corps aldo moro sera
prisonnier des brigades rouges pendant
55 jours et c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un vulgaire
terrorisme pour éliminer des ennemis
politiques ou pour affaiblir l'état
les brigades rouges public ou plutôt
fonds diffusées par la presse par la
radio la télévision des communiqués de
propagande et l'interrogatoire du
prisonnier aldo moro l'enlèvement est
exploité au maximum par les terroristes
il se trouve même des hommes politiques
qui sont disposés à traiter avec les
brigades rouges
les brigades rouges devienne une
véritable institution en italie il y
aura d'autres attentats sanglants
l'assassinât de magistrats d'industriels
ou de directeurs de prison
mais ce qui différencie les brigades
rouges des autres mouvements terroristes
c'est que cette organisation réussit à
exploiter à fond ses assassinats et
enlèvement
au début de l'année et pendant plus d'un
mois les brigades rouges vont créer un
véritable suspense autour du sort du
juge giovanni d'ours qui était enlevé
lui aussi par un commando en plein jour
en pleine rue entre temps d'ailleurs la
police et les carabiniers serait presque
sur le point d'affirmer que les
différents réseaux des brigades rouges
sont démantelés anéanti on ne compte
plus les découvertes de bases
terroristes les arrestations
il ya toute une série de procès contre
des membres des brigades rouges en
italie
on parle beaucoup de ces terroristes
repentis qui ont dénoncé leurs anciens
camarades de clandestinité
le dernier assassinat pratiqué par les
brigades rouges remonte au 3 août
c'est l'assassinât du frère de
terroristes repentis roberto pucci
pendant quatre mois ce sera le silence
qu'on pouvait espérer définitif et puis
hier il se produit quelque chose de très
nouveau
l'enlèvement d'un général américain ce
qui est nouveau évidemment c'est que les
brigades rouges essaie de se donner une
dimension internationale
en accord sans doute avec les
terroristes de l'allemagne fédérale qui
ont été les premiers à s'en prendre à
des militaires américains
seulement voilà cet enlèvement à un but
tellement précis c'est une attaque
tellement précise et directe contre les
états unis et l'otan que par exemple des
députés socialistes italiens se demande
si les brigades rouges ne sont pas en
train de participer à une stratégie anti
américaines qui seraient manipulés par
l'union soviétique les pays de l'est et
dans une moindre mesure par la libye
ce n'est pas la première fois que cette
question se pose mais c'est la première
fois qu'elle est posée ouvertement et
publiquement par des responsables
politiques italiens
[Musique]